first beyond our borders tonight a team  of researchers from the world health  organization who is in wuhan china  tonight  to investigate the origins of the  coronavirus pandemic  that visit has been shrouded in secrecy  with neither china  nor the w.h.o revealing exactly what the  team will do  where it will go or who it will talk to  a racing pigeon  survives an 8 thousand mile pacific  ocean crossing from the u.s  to find a new home in australia but get  this authorities there consider the bird  a quarantine risk and plan to kill it  experts suspect the pigeon named joe  after the president-elect  hits the ride on a cargo ship no word  from the aussies  whether pigeon joe will get a reprieve  just some of the other stories beyond  our borders tonight  we'll be right back